bowing America's largest aerospace  company was reportedly hit by a computer  virus today and their aspheric could  [ __ ] production of key aircraft  components Boeing's chief engineer  reportedly sent out a memo calling for  all hands on deck  the virus is identified as wanna cry  linked to North Korea which disabled  computers around the world last year  pilots in two different planes won a  Learjet the other in American Airlines  jet reported seeing a mysterious object  over Arizona last month we have learned  the exchange with air traffic control  sounded like something out of The  Twilight Zone don't know what it was but  at least two three thousand feet above  us the air pass right over the top  though no one has figured out what it  was other pilots did say they saw  nothing